everyone is listening to you now you
came by the tens of millions to become
part of a historic movement the likes of
which the world has never seen before
US President Donald Trump's victory is
part of a new wave of populism sweeping
through democracies of the world what
differentiates populist from mainstream
politicians is the claim that they alone
represent the will of the people as a
whole that allows them to dismiss any
opposition to themselves or their
policies as an attack on the popular
will
modern populist often take this approach
as they tap into the backlash against
immigration in a globalized economy that
many voters feel has left them behind
here's the situation
unlike most isms populism does not lean
left or right or even Center from the
late radical socialists Hugo Chavez of
Venezuela to the far-right nationalist
marine lepen in France the uniting
factor is how they conduct politics
according to one author there are three
core requirements for politicians to be
considered populist one they make an
appeal to the people championing their
cause against to despise the lead she
will keep our rigged system in place I
alone can fix it populist also use
crisis or manufacture them to justify
the call to revolt and lastly
inflammatory language is used to shock
the establishment and prove politicians
credentials as one of the people there
is a lot of Moroccan scum and holla to
makes the streets unsafe mr. Obama even
worse opinion here's the argument
because populist make big promises to
shake up society they tend to bump up
quickly against democratic checks and
balances in particular the courts and
media that were designed to limit what
governments can do the temptation
becomes to declare these institutions
part of an elite conspiracy to block the
people's will I have a running war with
the media they are among the most
dishonest human beings on earth
there's a reason why populists submerged
they promised a correction for
democracies that seem to have lost their
representative power and they offer a
fresh start
the challenge remains for mainstream
politicians to address widespread
economic and cultural fears otherwise
the draw of populism is not going away
anytime soon anything is possible if
enough decent people are prepared to
stand up against the establishment thank
you very much indeed
you